[Music]
well a few weeks ago we told you about a
new show on apple tv called gutsy it
follows the adventures of hillary
clinton and chelsea clinton as they sit
around planning jizzlane maxwell's
murder in prison
sorry that was that was the show concept
that apple turned down which is a shame
because it would be much better than
what they ended up with the real show
documents the clinton girls as they
traipse around the country talking to
women who inspire them women like
kim kardashian amy schumer wanda sykes
gloria steinem
serial killer eileen warnos
actually that last person was executed
which means that hillary will have to
wait a few years to talk to her anyway
it is without question
the worst show or film concept that
anyone has ever had i think i can say
that it makes batgirl look like a good
investment by comparison
if you didn't catch the trailer but or
even if you did we're gonna watch it
again here it is
we're hitting the road to shine a light
on women who inspire us to be bolder and
braver
leadership doesn't look one way you're
not gonna break me down you'll get worn
out before i do
i believe in second chances
[Applause]
every single person makes some impact on
the planet every day
[Applause]
we can choose what difference we make
[Music]
well we can only assume based on the
trailer that the name of the show gutsy
is meant to describe the courage
required of the viewers who are watching
it and i'm being very generous by saying
viewers with an s
now
we knew that a show starring the likes
of hillary clinton and kim kardashian
would just by its very existence be
brutal and torturous enough as to
violate every protocol of the geneva
convention but even the darkest
imagination could not have anticipated
just how bad it would actually be
because the show has now been released a
fact that comes as news to
everyone just as it will come as news to
any residents of connecticut that your
state has a wnba team by the way and
it's currently competing in the finals
and i learned that myself this morning
when i looked it up so that i could make
that joke hillary hillary's new show
debuted and people.com
has a summary of what we're all missing
by not watching it here's what it says
she might be a champion of gutsy women
but hillary clinton doesn't think it
should be an act of courage for women to
talk openly about the health and
function of their lady parts
as clinton's gutsy docu-series with
daughter chelsea premieres friday on
apple tv plus including episodes with
wanda sykes talking about menopause
and with migondi destalian talking about
her sex-positive whop the former
secretary of state recalls her own
experience with menopause and that
provocative rap now we do have a clip of
hillary's discussion about womp
uh believe me i would like to spare you
from having to watch it but i have no
choice your own sins have brought you to
this crossroads you must watch
as atonement for whatever evil you have
done in your life but before we endure
that trauma together
let's hear what hillary has to say about
menopause this should be at least
slightly less devastating to listen to
going back to the article says after a
certain age we all seem to inherit these
new things on our bodies hillary 74
tells people it was towards the end of
the second term after i turned 50 in
1997 that i began to go through
menopause and it was something that you
didn't talk about in those days my
friends and i would talk about it or
roll our eyes but not publicly that's
why we really wanted to talk about it
with wanda because it's a universal
experience for us thank goodness we're
getting into a time when women's health
and especially now with all the
challenges about reproductive health are
forcing this conversation out of the
shadows and into the daylight
now hillary insists that somehow her
menopause has something to do with the
abortion conversation continuing quote
it's astonishing to me how ignorant a
lot of these men legislators are in a
lot of these states making these laws
about women's bodies she says
the things they say the things that they
think the ignorance that they display is
breathtaking so the more we can talk
about it chelsea jumps in it's dangerous
stigma is so deadly when it comes to
public health hillary acknowledges
stigma played a role in her silence in
the white house
looking back i mean it wasn't yet at the
point of our social or psychic
development that i would have said oh
okay the first lady is going through
menopause here i go watch out everybody
now a couple of things here
first to fruitlessly reiterate
it's not just men who support pro-life
laws it's actually not even mostly men
also i'm not sure of a single example
where pro-life legislation has betrayed
an ignorance of women's bodies we're all
aware that women's bodies bear children
we know that i mean we know that
those of us on the right are aware of
that it's actually on the left where
there's confusion on that point but on
our side we know that our point is
simply that
these children should not be killed
that's all we're saying
but second perhaps more to the point
here hillary says that back in the 90s
we weren't at the point of our social
psychic development where the first lady
would announce her menopause publicly
well are we at that point now
should we be
why would you want to make a public
announcement about your menopause
she says that she talked about her
menopause with her friends but she
didn't talk about it on the public stage
yes and
what else would you have done held a
press conference
issued an official statement on white
house letterhead called for a national
day of mourning obviously you didn't
talk about your menopause publicly that
would have been totally bizarre and
weird and inappropriate
besides the public was hearing more than
enough already about the various bodily
functions occurring in the white house
during the clinton administration so we
didn't need to hear more let me ask you
something what if there was someone out
there who kept a log of every single
thing you did every minute of the day
what if i told you that's exactly what
happens every time you go online your
internet provider like at t or comcast
is allowed to store logs of every
website you've ever visited and can
legally sell this data to anyone that's
why i always use expressvpn expressvpn
reroute your internet connection through
their secure server so your internet
provider can't see or log what you do
online
now many of you might be wondering well
if i'm routing all my data through a vpn
then doesn't that just mean the vpn can
see what i'm doing and log my data
instead well you're right to think that
many vpns claim to have a no logs policy
but have been caught logging activity
all the same expressvpn is the only vpn
i trust because they use trusted server
technology this makes it impossible for
their vpn servers to store any data
including logs of any expressvpn
customer you don't have to take my or
expressvpn's word for it expressvpn is
so confident in their no logs claimed
they even had one of the biggest
assurance firms audit their technology
so stop letting people keep logs of what
you do online visit expressvpn.com
matt wall show right now and find out
how you can get three months free
we have this totally ridiculous idea in
our culture that
if we don't discuss something publicly
then it's it's stigmatized
feminists will say the same thing about
their periods they lament the
stigmatization of a woman's menstrual
cycle
but again there's no stigma we're all
aware that it's a thing that happens in
and to the bodies of women that doesn't
mean that we all need to talk about it
over the dinner table or that you need
to announce it into a megaphone
you also don't need to make a public
pronouncement about every fart or burp
or bowel movement these are all things
that everyone does yet we are
discouraged from making a spectacle out
of these activities doesn't mean we're
oppressed it just means that we're
expected to be at least moderately
civilized
but there are those for whom moderately
civilized is a bar too high to get over
those like megan estalion who appeared
in another episode of the show where she
and hillary and chelsea had the
conversation that you were hoping i
would forget about and not play the clip
of but today is not your lucky day so
here it is
chelsea follows rap music she has
ever since she was a little girl
but i kind of
came to awareness of you with the cardi
b whap
i've always wanted to do a song with
cardi as soon as she sent me the song i
think i sent it back to her like the
next day and it was just so exciting the
men they seem so confident in what
they're saying and they don't have no
problem with talking about their
sexuality and how they're gonna have sex
with you so i was like well
i could do that and it's gonna sound
fire coming from a woman it's great to
see women be so kind of fierce that is
my
life's mission
to make sure that i'm always
unapologetically me
yes well on the bright side
negan says that she took a day to write
her verse of the song which is a lot
longer than i thought it would have
taken she put more thought into it than
i assumed i'll give her that
after all her contribution to the song
indeed the whole song itself is the sort
of thing that an illiterate crackhead
could scribble on a bathroom stall in
about 95 seconds while in the middle of
overdosing
but she was more thoughtful than that
which i mean perhaps makes it all the
more pathetic but
whatever the case and and if we can
somehow move past the intense revulsion
we feel about the way this subject is
being discussed and especially about who
is discussing it
the lessons being taught here are truly
terrible
first megan notes that uh male rappers
are disgusting pigs constantly you know
saying very crass and sexual things
her way of correcting this problem is to
be an even more disgusting pig herself
this truly is the feminist mantra
i hate it when men behave in
objectionable ways so i will behave in
an even more objectionable way she then
claims that her life's mission is to be
unapologetically me
that is of course the worst sort of
mission you can have in life it is a
recipe for failure in 99.9 of cases
the rap and pop industries package this
kind of message and they sell it to kids
forgetting to mention that almost none
of them will end up as successful as the
celebrities they're emulating if they
continue to emulate them
because unapologetically me in this
context means
i'm going to be a stupid boorish
self-centered obnoxious idiot
and expect everyone to just fall over
themselves and worship me anyway because
i'm me
the celebrities who promote this mission
this message will indeed themselves be
worshipped no matter how dumb and
repulsive they are but for most people
being dumb and repulsive just means that
nobody will want to be around you or be
your friend or marry you or hire you for
a job
you will be alone and bitter and
miserable forever
but you will have helped me gone the
stallion get rich and that's all she
cares about
and that's why she is canceled and
hillary clinton is cancelled and this
show is especially most certainly
in the end canceled
well if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the subscribe button and ring the
bell to get more content like it if
you're craving more content go watch or
listen to my full show at dailywire.com
spotify or wherever you get your podcast